esta es la reacción de di el saler es
una reacción muy famosa en química
orgánica debido a su utilidad en la
síntesis orgánica llegó a ser tan útil
que 10 y albert recibieron el premio
nobel por el descubrimiento de esta
reacción aquí del lado izquierdo tenemos
un día no conjugado lo escribiré
este es nuestro bien que es
relativamente rico en electrones tiene
un montón de electrones pi y la molécula
del lado derecho se llama de no filo
este es nuestro 10 no filo
y lo que significa amante entonces el 10
nov y lo ama al bien o porque el bien o
filo es relativamente pobre en
electrones debido a la presencia de este
grupo aceptar de electrones en un
momento lo veremos con más detalle así
que tomaremos a estas dos moléculas y
calentaremos un poco obtendremos un
producto de 10
alder y para obtener el producto de 10
alder necesitamos tener un movimiento de
electrones p entonces si pensamos en el
mecanismo para la reacción de 10
alder sabemos que el lleno es
relativamente rico en electrones así que
podemos pensar en electrones moviéndose
del bien o al bien o filo
estos electrones se moverán del bien o
al bien o filo y formaremos un enlace
justo aquí eso significaría muchos
enlaces para este carbono en el bien o
filo entonces estos electrones pi
también se moverán al mismo tiempo se
moverán hacia arriba para formar un
enlace entre estos dos carbonos y eso
significaría muchos enlaces para este
carbono así que podemos pensar que estos
electrones en color rosa se moverán
hacia abajo para formar un doble enlace
estos 6 electrones que se mueven al
mismo tiempo en este mecanismo y
formarán un anillo de 6 miembros
dibujemos el producto de piel
alder obtenemos un anillo de 6 miembros
con un doble enlace justo aquí y el
grupo aceptar de electrones está unido
al anillo por acá
si seguimos a los electrones para los de
color naranja formaron este enlace
simple los electrones py en color azul
formaron este enlace simple por acá y
los electrones en color rosa formaron el
doble enlace cuando pensamos en estos
seis electrones moviéndose al mismo
tiempo decimos que es un mecanismo
concertado dibujemos el estado de
transición para un mecanismo concertado
y les mostraré los seis electrones py
moviéndose al mismo tiempo pondré la
cadena principal de carbonos para el
bien y la cadena principal para el bien
o filo
con el grupo aceptar de electrones unido
aquí
los electrones py en el hielo están
fluyendo hacia el bien o filo se forma
este enlace y eso ocurre al mismo tiempo
que este enlace se está formando que
también ocurre al mismo tiempo que los
electrones en el bien o se mueven aquí
entonces todos estos electrones se
mueven al mismo tiempo este es el estado
de transición de 6 electrones pi
estado de transición
de 6 electrones pi en un mecanismo
concertado 6 electrones pi es un número
mágico en términos de estabilidad pero
para entender completamente una reacción
de 10 salde hay que saber un poco más
sobre la teoría del orbital molecular de
lo que hablaremos en otros vídeos
entonces estos 6 electrones que se
mueven al mismo tiempo para formar un
anillo de 6 miembros se dice que esto es
una reacción de ciclo adición ciclo
adición 424 por los cuatro carbonos en
el lleno y dos por los carbonos con los
que trabajamos en el bien o filo por eso
es 42 hagamos otro problema esta vez
enfoquémonos en los grupos aceptar es de
electrones veamos por qué son necesarios
para obtener una buena producción o una
buena reacción
de piel sal de empecemos con un día no
sencillo y pongamos un día no filo con
un grupo aceptar de electrones por aquí
ahí está vamos a calentar ahora pensemos
en nuestro 10 no filo con este grupo
aceptar de electrones una forma sería
dibujando las estructuras de resonancia
redibujar a nuestro 10 no filo por acá
cuáles serían las posibles estructuras
de resonancia para este bien o filo
bueno podemos tomar estos electrones py
en el carbón y lo y moverlos hacia el
oxígeno
entonces si dibujamos la estructura de
resonancia ahora el oxígeno tiene tres
pares de electrones libres eso le da una
carga formal negativa y como le quitamos
un enlace a este carbono tiene una carga
formal positiva
aún podemos dibujar otra estructura de
resonancia estos electrones y ahora se
moverán hacia acá y formarán un doble
enlace y entonces otra estructura nos
queda así
aún tiene esta carga formal negativa en
el oxígeno pero esta vez le quitamos un
enlace a este carbono así que la carga
positiva ahora se encuentra justo aquí
hemos terminado con las estructuras de
resonancia y observen que el oxígeno al
ser tan electro negativo tomo densidad
electrónica de esta parte de la molécula
y por eso el carbono termina con una
carga formal positiva podemos decir que
este carbono es parcialmente positivo al
igual que este otro y claro el oxígeno
tiene una carga parcial negativa eso
incrementa la reactividad del 10 no filo
si pensamos en el mecanismo estos
electrones cargados negativamente estos
electrones
eran atraídos a lo que esté cargado
positivamente es decir a este carbono
con la carga parcial positiva y eso
inicia nuestro mecanismo de ty el saldo
estos electrones en azul también se
moverán para formar un enlace y estos
electrones en rosa se moverán hacia
abajo así que cuando dibujamos el
producto nos queda un anillo de 6
miembros con un doble enlace justo aquí
y unido a este carbono está el grupo
aceptar de electrones así nos queda
nuestro producto los electrones en color
naranja se movieron hacia acá los
electrones en color azul se movieron
aquí y los electrones en rosa formaron
este doble enlace así queda nuestro
producto
hagamos otro ejemplo esta vez vamos a
enfocarnos en el bien es posible empezar
con undiano que tenga esta conformación
ésta es la conformación más estable ese
trans
normalmente cuando hablamos de cis y
trans nos referimos a los al que nos
pero aquí la conformación es trans con
respecto a este enlace sigma sin embargo
un día no de conformación ese trans no
reacciona en un mecanismo de 10 alder
pero como este enlace rota libremente
puede cambiar la conformación de ese
trans a ese sis
en donde los dobles enlaces están del
mismo lado si tenemos a nuestro bien
como decís ya puede ocurrir la reacción
de ti el sal de ahora dibujemos al bien
o filo esta vez pondré un alc y no es
posible tener algunos ya que tienen
electrones pi y por acá dibujaré un
grupo aceptar de electrones pondré un
grupo carbón hilo y luego un oxígeno y
un mitin
y pondré lo mismo abajo
ya que tenemos estos dos reactivos y
aplicamos un poco de calor ahora
pensemos en el mecanismo bueno estos
electrones py en el alc y no se moverán
hacia acá para formar un nuevo enlace y
luego estos electrones en color rosa se
moverán hacia abajo para formar un doble
enlace al mismo tiempo que estos
electrones de naranja se mueven hacia
acá dibujemos el producto nuevamente
obtuvimos un anillo de 6 miembros con un
al que no en el lado izquierdo y como le
quitamos un enlace al triple enlace eso
significa que también terminamos con un
al que no del lado derecho y después
tenemos estos grupos saliendo del anillo
así nos queda nuestro producto una vez
más sigamos a los electrones los
electrones de color naranja formaron
este enlace los electrones en azul
formaron este enlace y finalmente los
electrones en rosa formaron este doble
enlace esta fue una introducción a la
reacción de 10
alder vimos el mecanismo y las
estructuras del 10 y el 10 no filo lo
siguiente será involucrar la estéreo
química del lleno y el bien o filo con
lo que será un poco más complicado